-We're hanging out with
Liam Hemsworth, everybody.
His film "Isn't It Romantic" out
Wednesday February 13th.
Liam and I are about to face off
in a game of "Catchphrase,
but first we're going
to need partners,
and we found some good ones.
Joining Liam's team, you kno
her from "2 Dope Queens,"
which returns to HBO
this Friday,
please welcome Jessica Williams.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi.
-How you doing?
-Whoo-hoo!
-My partner tonight
is a three-time
Super Bowl champion, a tight end
for the New England Patriots
give it up for Rob Gronkowski.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How you doing?
-Thanks so much.
Congrats again, buddy.
-Hi. Hello, hello.
-What's happening?
How you doing?
-Nice to meet you.
-Yes. You, too.
-Okay, guys.
Here's how the game works.
Liam, you'll start the round b
pressing start on this buzzer,
and then you draw a clue
from the top of the pile.
You have to get
your partner to guess
the clue
as quickly as possible
then hand the buzzer off
to the person on your right.
You can make any physical
gesture, say whatever you want
but you can't say any word
in the actual clue.
If you're holding the buzzer
when it goes off,
your team loses that round
We'll play three rounds.
Let's take our positions. Ready?
-Yeah.
-Here we go.
Jessica, you're there.
-Okay. Exciting.
-Yeah. And that's you, buddy
right there.
Are you competitive?
-Yeah, I'm really comp--
I'm a Leo,
so I'm ready to roll whenever.
I can talk crap like anybody
-Yeah, it looks like you -
-You're the worst. You're th
worst. And we're going to win.
-Oh, my gosh.
-That's the harshest trash tal
I have ever heard.
-Wow. And you play NFL football.
Here we go. Alright.
You start off.
You press the buzzer
and then take the first clue
-Alright.
-And best of luck, really.
I really hope
you have a good time.
-Okay.
[ Beeping ]
Opposite of really low
singing voice.
-High, alto, soprano.
Oh, my God.
Falsetto.
-Yeah. There you go.
-Yeah!
-Oh, my gosh.
-Wow.
-All right, go.
-That was good.
-Take this, Gronk.
-You're on the ground, and
you're doing a motion like this.
-The worm.
-Yes, yes!
-Wow!
-He's played before.
-Oh, man. It's a Mexican food.
Not a taco,
but a -- a flat taco.
-A burrito?
-With cheese. No. Oh, man.
-Tortilla.
-Yeah, no!
Oh, but it's wrapped around some
cheese, and you lay it flat.
-Enchilada.
-You lay it flat.
-You lay it flat?
-Yeah.
-What do you lay flat?
-It's like a taco on the side!
Oh, man! You can put,
like, chicken in it.
-I'm Australian. I'm Australian.
-I know! I know!
[ Buzzer ]
Okay.
Oh, my God! Oh, my God!
-Quesadilla?
-It was a quesadilla.
I am so sorry!
A taco on the side.
-A taco on the side.
-Wow! I am so sorry.
-Wow.
-That's alright.
-I'm surprised you didn't get it
from "taco on the side."
-That's alright, boo.
We gonna get it.
-All right. Here we go.
That was great, buddy.
Alright. Here we go.
[ Beeping ]
Okay, uh, not long pants.
-Short pants. Short shorts
-Yes!
-Yeah! Whoo!
-Okay, an exercise move
where you go to here.
-Squats!
-There you go!
-Yeah!
-Alright.
-They're a type of shoe and --
-Clogs.
Crocs.
-Yeah! Yeah!
-What?!
-Who is this guy?
-Okay, we're not --
When you like something,
you're giving it some applause
but not fast.
You're going to do it...
-Slow clap.
-Yeah!
-Wow!
-"Always after me..."
It's a cereal.
It's a little leprechaun.
It's a cereal with all sorts o
different marshmallows in it
-Oh, Lucky Charms!
-Yes!
[ Buzzer ]
Yes! We won that one, too!
-No!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We were on fire!
-He cheated.
At one moment, I thought
you were looking over.
Kind of looked like
you saw his card.
-I never did that.
-I'm gonna have to side with -
I felt that, as well.
-Guys, we're going to play
one more round.
-One more round.
-And this one is worth
10,000 points.
Whoever wins this
wins the whole game.
-Here we go.
-Alright, focus up, buddy.
-All or nothing.
-Here we go.
Let's start with you, Liam
-All right. We got this.
-Here we go. Ready?
-Yeah.
[ Beeping ]
-Um, God. I'm not cold.
-Hot.
-Yep, okay. First word.
Next part -- I'm all...
-Wet. Dry. Sad. Slow.
-I'm a hot -- Ugh!
-A hot dude. Hot guy?
You're a hot guy.
-It's all --
Everything's everywhere.
-Everything's messy. Hot mess!
-Hot mess!
-Yeah! There, go.
[ Beeping ]
[ Laughter ]
-I don't even know the word.
-What?
-Can I pass?
-No, you can't pass!
-I don't know.
-What are you talking about?
-I just don't know. It's long.
It's an instrument.
-Australian instrument.
-It's a didgeridoo!
-Yes!
-What?!
-I knew it!
-Oh! Use the force, you must
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, that's it.
There, we got it.
Didgeridoo. We won.
Wow. Didgeridoo.
-What are the rules of that?
Oh, God.
I'm, like, mad.
-Our thanks to Liam Hemsworth,
Jessica Williams,
Rob Gronkowski.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's time to "Tonight Show:
Family Feud."
Give it up for Steve Harvey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-How you folks doing today
Well, that's good.
-Yeah,
-It's great.
Hey, how's everybody
doing tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, folks.
Welcome to "Family Feud:
Tonight Show
Family Feud Edition."
I'm your man, Steve Harvey
-That's what I'm talking about
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we got one
for you tonight, folks.
From New York, New York,
it's the Fallon family.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And from the City of
-Brotherly Love, Philly, Philly,
Philly, sounds like Philly me,
it's The Roots firmly.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
The guns, brothers.
Really?
Really, really.
Just couldn't of thought
of nothing else,
but them damn guns.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, let's go.
It's time to play Feud.
Give me Jimmy.
Give Questlove. Let's go
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Okay, folks.
We polled 100
TV audience members right here
top three answers on the board
Here we go.
Name another term for marijuana.
Quest.
-Weed.
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good answer.
-He clearly -- he clearly
does not smoke weed.
That's why he was so fast
on the draw, clearly.
Yeah, but he got number on
answer right off like that
Good. How are you doing?
-I'm doing great.
Tariq, You're ready?
Yes, sir, yes sir.
Alright. Let's go.
Name another term
for marijuana, Tariq.
You can't ask him.
-Reefer.
-Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry.
Sorry, I apologize.
-I'm the host of this show
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Reefer.
[ Buzzer, audience groans
-What?
-That's a big break,
Reefer is a hood reference
You have strike.
We only go to strikes, right
Two strikes. Hey, Jimmy.
Jimmy.
I got this.
Just relax.
I already know.
We're only doing two strikes
-Okay.
There's one strike
on the board,
so you got to be careful.
The Fallon family can steal.
James, name another term
for marijuana.
-Ganja.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ganja..
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Booyaka!
Booyaka! Booyaka!
-Where you go? Jamaica.
-We're back to you, Questlove.
You got one strike,
got to be careful.
Family, family, family --
Fallon family can steal.
Name another
the term for marijuana.
Pot.
-Whoo! Good answer.
-Pot.
[ Buzzer, audience groans
[ Indistinct talking ]
You supposed to huddle up.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey.
-You huddle up, Jimmy.
-Sorry.
-Play the game right.
-I did. I'm playing it right
-We're already tight.
-Great job, guys.
Okay,
here's your chance to steal.
Name another term for marijuana.
-Gra-- Grass.
[ Laughter ]
-Grass?
What?
-What is grass.
-Who the hell says grass?
-Grass
-Whose grandmama
is in this damn survey?
You stop smoking that grass.
It's grass.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheering ]
-What is it?
Alright, our remaining answer,
number two.
-Chronic?
-Mary Jane.
-Hey, let's move on
to question two.
-Come on.
-Give me Jason.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Who the hell is...?
Tariq, let's go.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is it.
-Top three answers
on the board again, guys.
Here we go.
-Good answer.
Good answer.
[ Laughter ]
Name an instrument
least likely
to get a band member groupies.
Tariq.
-Tuba
-Oh!
Oh, snap! Oh, snap!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-No groupies for the tub--
for the Tuba man.
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They gonna play.
-Don't worry about it.
-They are mopping y'all.
-I know, I know, I know.
-This business right here.
That's what got them.
You're scared to answer
the question.
Alright, James, let's go.
Name an instrument least
likely to get
a band member groupies.
-The accordion.
-Good answer
-The accordion?
-Yes.
-Yes, the accordion.
-Who has an accordion
in the band?
-You talking about our band?
-No, I'm not. You --
You just -- you just going wit
the audience members, right?
-Yeah.
-You think they said that?
-I think so.
[ Laughter ]
-Accordion.
[ Buzzer ]
-Who would say that?
Who the hell would say
accordion?
These people don't know nothin
about no accordion.
Who say that?
Quest, name an instrument
least likely
to get a band member groupies.
-Be honest, Quest.
-What you saying, Jimmy Fallon
[ Laughter ]
-If I was them, I would give
a rimshot right now.
[ Laughter ]
Say it! Say it!
-The flute.
-Good answer, good answer.
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
One answer left.
-Who's doing this poll?
-[ Indistinct talking ]
-They are
whooping y'all's tail, man
-I don't know what's
going on, man.
-One answer left.
If it's there,
you clear the board.
Name an instrument
least likely
to get a band member groupies.
-I'm going to say triangle
-What?
-Good answer, good answer.
-Triangle.
-Good answer.
-Stop.
Stop clapping.
Nobody said
no damn triangle.
It's as stupid
as that accordion.
Who the hell going
to say triangle?
Look at your audience.
Why would they say triangle?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, let's find out.
Triangle.
[ Buzzer ]
-Here we go.
[ Indistinct conversation
[ Laughter ]
-That was two strikes.
Yeah, that's it.
Okay, let's go. Here we go
Hey, hey, hey.
Name an instrument
least likely to get
a band member groupies.
Come on, fellas.
-Drums.
-What?
What were we --
-Drums.
What were we thinking again?
I forgot.
Oh,
-Tambourine or something.
-No.
Oh, right.
We have the answer.
-There's a time limit.
-Sorry. Tr--
Trombone.
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to go with --
Let me go with trombone.
[ Laughter ]
You know, when they get
too close to the microphone.
-Yes.
That's what they do
to people at home
that never been on TV.
-I like to see Trombone.
They talk real loud.
-[ Indistinct talking ]
Do we have [indistinct]
[ Laughter ]
That covers all my bases.
-Let's see. Trombone.
[ Buzzer ]
-Whoo!
-Wow.
Let's see what our
remaining answer is.
Number two.
Bass.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Bass get a lot of play, man
-Alright. Okay, let's go to ou
third and final question.
Give me Higgins.
Give me James.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Here we go, guys.
Because this last round,
this one is worth triple the
points, so it's anybody's game
You can make a comeback.
-Okay.
You guys are killing us.
-Yes, they are.
We have the top
three answers on the board
-Come on.
-Fill in the blank.
-Oh, wow.
-One hand on the board, guy.
[ Laughter ]
Fill in the blank.
I love to play with my what?
Steve.
Yeah, they say it. Say it.
-What is ding dong?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What are you doing?
You can't -- you can't chang
your answer.
-It just popped in my head
-This ain't "Jeopardy.
-You're right. I'm sorry.
-What is my ding dong.
What is it?
-You're right.
-I don't know what it is.
-I quit.
-I know what my ding dong is
Is that is question?
-I know what
is ding dong is, too.
-Survey says.
-Your ding dong.
[ Buzzer, audience groans
-James, I love to play
with my...
-Excuse me.
Excuse me.
-Ball.
[ Laughter ]
-Your balls?
-No.
-Did he say bong?
-No, that's not what you said.
Your balls.
You get your ass over there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Balls.
-I said ball.
-Ball.
-Basketball.
-That's not what he's said
No, he meant --
-It's singular.
-No, he hung his down.
He said balls.
-No!
-Nobody goes -- nobody goe
pass their ding dong,
pass that up to play
with their balls.
Nobody does that.
[ Laughter ]
You don't go past it.
-I don't --
I don't want to debate this.
-Let's go. Here it is.
You want -- Fallon, run your -
Your balls.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay.
-I said ball.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, I'm trying to follo
the instructions.
Wrap it up.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
We have a winner.
It's the Questlove family.
We'll see next time.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Steve Harvey, everybody!
-Yeah.